good health day to him and jaramillo
with the most outstanding headlines of the
day the two
men arrested for their participation
in the assault on the capitol last month will remain jailed
the defendants script materia and bank of
england appeared before a judge on
monday and face multiple
Federal charges describe a Las
Vegas resident appearing on surveillance video
inside the Capitol while
Tennessee state examination images circulated online showing him
smoking marijuana inside the
federal building during the riot,
and prosecutors said Monday that both
men were  seen pushing
police officers a
preliminary hearing to describe was scheduled
for next february 16
therefore both men will remain in
jail
the las vegas convention center
opened the vaccine clinic today
the public is reminded that this  center will
only be for people who need to
receive the second dose  In
addition, the second dose will only be administered
to people who
received the first dose at clinics
in the Southern Nevada Health District,
including the Was In High
School and the Crack Center. The center
will operate Tuesday through Saturday from 8 a.m.  and a half
to 3 pm in the afternoon for more information you
can visit youtube.com officials
from the state health sector
reported that more than 253,000 vaccines
have been administered in Nevada the
number reported with all people
vaccinated until January 31 among the
challenges  that the state has faced is being
able to ensure that the dose is
administered to people who are in the
first tier to receive it. It is expected
that the vaccination process and challenges
will be topics on the agenda today on the
second day of the state legislative session.
county commissioners will be
reviewing bicyclist safety today
it is anticipated that the commissioners will
consider clarifying the bicycling rules
that t
The issue
of cyclist safety has been on the
agenda just two months after
five cyclists were struck
on Highway 95 near the town of
Searchlight and the driver
of the truck that struck them is suspected of driving
under the influence.  of a substance
now we pass with your
weather forecast a partially sunny day is expected
with temperatures above
normal the maximum close to 67 degrees and
minimum in the 40s and get ready because
the winds are approaching have a good day
I am salt and rockrose  mine and this was news
now in Spanish
[Music]